I think God calls all of us to fill
different roles at different times and I
think that he wanted Donald Trump to
become president wonder if God wanted me
to do this job thank you the devil made
you do this instantly mocking Sarah
Sanders though for that comment he did
it even God was like what the hell I
can't take my eyes off you people for a
minute well if he did it's because he
wanted to punish us for taking our
democracy for granted this president is
actually the antithesis of Jesus crisis
teachings I believe that God called me
to to make sure that people know that
Donald Trump is not the dude
so what we're both called alright
Sanders also taking aim at the White
House press corps for grandstanding
during briefings this isn't everybody
and I don't want to generalize the crowd
but I mean you do you see a lot of like
angry faces people that their sole
purpose is to find this gotcha moment to
catch you their job is not to get
information which is what the briefing
is supposed to be it's to trip you up
and I think if the briefing you know
loses purpose and it isn't a good
resource for the American people to get
information and answers to real
questions then you do have to wonder if
that's the best forum in order to put a
message out well going back to the top
Greg I bet the media is thanking God
every day Trump's president oh my god
headline are you kidding me they're bait
they're making more money than ever the
publishing industry especially I think
this is it's okay for the for Kimmel and
everybody to make jokes about it they
were actually pretty funny but it is an
example of a media mocking a good it's a
Christian displaying their faith openly
when we know they would dare not do that
if she had cited him the Muslim God or a
Buddhist prophet or whatever if they had
she's got in any other direction if
anybody done that and never would have
happened I I think she probably meant he
was the right person for the right
time I don't profess to know what God
wants and I am always skeptical when
people say that when he wants what's
best for you I know I know but when
people cite religion as a motivating for
an action I go I just go you can't know
that I know what you mean you're saying
this is for the best
but I you know I'm always very skeptical
of that now I'm gonna shut up and I'm
going to hell alright bring him on what
about isn't over here I wanted to get
Katie's perspective charlie rangel
thanks God Barack Obama was president
said God put Obama in the White House
Obama said that he was gonna lower the
sea level so I think Obama thought that
maybe he was actually God now look I
mean she has her own beliefs yes there
are the beliefs of of millions of people
around the country and the mainstream
media and the comedian's can make fun of
it all they want they have the right to
do so but it goes to show that they're
willing to continue to insult millions
of people who agree with the Trump
administration and the people that
support them what do you think won I
don't think that was I think you and
Gregg said you know that's her beliefs
let her have them but I don't think you
guys buy it I mean to me if you look at
the 10 commandments is this say oh it's
okay to lie it's okay to cheat on your
wife it's okay to hang around with porn
stars I mean I it's wrong with that last
part wrong with that last part that's
not in the commandments what about the
paying them off with hush money that's
okay too
it's a color probe the Russian god bless
them the Russians must have been
instructed by God to go after Sanders
say that Donald Trump was a perfectly
moral person she simply said she
believes that God put him in place to do
the job what a choice what a choice hey
Dana what do you think about the comment
also about what you said about the White
House press can I talk about the other
thing too that ever you want so and
remember that the interview was given to
the Christian Broadcasting Network right
okay so a piece of information people no
one told me that it was aa kid Greg and
read the bill when George Bush was
president that they made fun of george w
bush for years
there was I can't remember the exact
details but along the way somebody said
that he felt called to do this and
they're like oh so he and it was the
same type of an tip an antipathy for
people that are Christian or whatever
you are like you're right like I don't
know what Buddhists believe but I'm
assuming Buddhist think that you're in
the right place at the right time or
that okay all of that there's that about
like the ten commandments and they're
frustrated but Christians also believe
in forgiveness and we don't know what is
in his heart and what he has asked God
for and what sort of forgive that's like
none of our business guess what the
great thing is we don't have to decide
he gets a judge you know that it could
be a she Dana it also could be a she not
I want to make a point on this yes so
one day I was interviewing your former
boss yep George W Bush and afterwards I
got so much flak from my bosses for
saying oh but mr. president in my church
we pray for you every Sunday and people
said why would you say that to George
this is the thing about okay and you
know what you know what George W Bush
used to say when people said we're
praying for you sir he would say thank
you I can feel it oh okay so but then
the media would make fun of that you
know the media for the last two years
has spent a lot of time they send
reporters out go see America go figure
out how we got it so wrong and this is
part of the reason why we can let them
have that to your point of why the in
the press off the room I think it's it's
not that they're just trying to trip you
up in the press room the wonder how do
you make news one of the ways you make
news is if you find inconsistency it's
not just that oh you're gonna tell me
these things and I write them dutifully
down and I don't get to argue back and
say well that doesn't wash with this and
a lot of people in the room are
frustrated but they were maybe called
fake news on something and it only turns
out four months later that that was
actually true so that is why they look
for inconsistency they're trying to
break news but maybe it hurts her that
her president says that the press is the
enemy of the American people right for
president Trump at church every Sunday
Oh God keep it up Juan you're doing a
great job